isn't it just time for women to run the
planet I I mean here is Will Ferrell
Hollywood actor Will Ferrell who is
Ferell Ferell will Ferell yes that
sounds weird to me is Hollywood actor
Will Ferell he is at the women in
entertainment Gala held at the Beverly
Hills Hotel and here he is explaining
that the day of the man is coming to a
close forget about the entertainment
world isn't it isn't it just time
isn't it just time for women to run the
planet I I
mean I'm I'm s I'm not just trying to PL
you I
swear but I don't know what else to do
because
we men uh we've been running the show
since what 10,000 BC something like that
and we're not doing so good
so please can you guys just take over
I'm not trying to Plate you here's the
most pandering dous nonsense I could
possibly say yes okay women just run the
world men retire men stop working
underground you know in septic tanks and
buildings and climbing High to do all
these crazy things and getting out there
and doing engineering and fixing things
stop doing women will just take over
women will they want like some sort of
like Bizarro woke planet of the ape
situation that is what these people want
they men will live in cages and women
will run rampant and lesbians will take
over and it's just like that really is
my Theory and action right there
like will I have just no doubt that Will
Ferrell's wife is a feminist right and
this guy and he also works in Hollywood
so he wants to stay in good with the
Woks but at the end of the day does he
really think women should rule it's just
nonsense saying women should rule the
world is as nonsensical as saying just
men should rule the world right like you
should judge people individually some
women are great authors some men are
great authors but not every woman like
you get it you get it anyway the guy
just wants a blow job he just wants a
but but who doesn't at the end
of the
day